what's going on reject nation happy
monday
first off i want to say thank you to
everyone who watched our godzilla versus
kong trailer reaction yesterday
we hit trending on youtube so thank you
guys so much for watching that that's
it's always a nice feeling especially
kickoff 2021 that way that's really nice
thank you with that in mind
want to check out from our buddy chris
over at 3c films he put out a video
five theories from the godzilla versus
kong trailer to blow
your mind if you haven't subscribed to
3c films we've been covering some of his
videos lately
please do yourself a favor check out his
content he's put out some great godzilla
versus kong videos like months in
advance
leading up to this trailer i was gonna
watch this on my own time and i was like
you know what we should just do a
reaction to it and talk about what he's
got to talk about because
i trust his word
the married cheeks are gone
you can't tell me you dodge a blast like
that
without them just disappeared hey god
delivers people
fans my name is
that was that's believable exactly
all day today
and my general thoughts on everything
going on really tried posting my
actual trailer reaction where i first
saw the trailer but youtube apparently
wanted to be some hoes so
i know the pain man i know the pain
now the most popular theories that fans
are having now that we've seen
the godzilla vs kong trailer have a much
better idea to what is actually
happening
in the monster universe and also like
why the hell are they making godzilla
out to be the bad guy look i'm team
harry cheeks all the way
[Laughter]
marketing choice well we all kind of
know what's going on now so be sure you
guys are also leaving your thoughts down
below
your opinions which one you agree with
on my list which one did you disagree
with
open to any discussion but hit that like
button and also
subscribe so close to hitting 250k would
mean a lot
he did so let's dive into the first year
we have going on celebration for chris
congratulations we got to get you to a
million buddy just wanted to point that
out really quick
subscribe to him and that is mecca
godzilla it is without a question
we will be seeing the robocop godzilla
show up
in this film not only because it was
literally like the first time
coming out of the trailer you really
thought we wouldn't notice but we
noticed
and then the not so subtle but obvious
confirmation of the blueprints in the
background that's
the blueprint everyone was talking about
because
being created by epics all that was left
is how did they come to the creation of
mechagodzilla the most popular theory
going on right now with this is it comes
from two things that has already been
set up in the monster universe first
back in the 2014 godzilla movie we saw
bones of an older godzilla that was
destroyed and then we had no idea what
happened to those bones
flash forward to the ending of king of
monsters where we had another company
separate from our getting the ghidorah
head and using it for once
that's gonna be such a cool movie of
course people really hope that it would
be
the mecca ghidorah combining these two
it seems like the way mechagodzilla is
gonna come to life
is using the skeleton bones from those
godzilla remains in the 2014 movie
pairing it up with the brain if that was
left over from king of monsters
using the actual brain as a form of ai
to power the suit and get it going would
also be a perfect explanation
for why it goes wrong for why it can't
be controlled
by godzilla and king kong would have to
step
in to take care of this thing really
with everything being set up it would be
a waste not to use all that stuff
that they've been sure sure really just
go ahead and say that they've made the
mega godzilla purely from robotic parts
and ai engineering
then what the hell is the point of all
those easter eggs you were throwing at
us
before we get to another very popular
mechagodzilla theory involving a fake
godzilla let's talk about the battle axe
origin
probably the most well let's slow down a
little bit let's slow down a little bit
all right so this image everyone in the
comments was like yeah you see
blueprints mechagodzilla
and i honestly didn't spot this one it's
like it was pointed out to us in the
middle of our discussion
after doing the reaction by my fiance
did you catch makeup god's i don't know
if you guys saw that moment
but but yeah like oh you do see him
clearly
in the shot what i love that's being
pointed out in chris's video
from like the bones tease in the first
godzilla and then yeah this is the main
thing i heard about king ghidorah's head
that they would be using this to
essentially make make a godzilla and i
think that's really neat if that
was part of their original plan when
they started this film franchise because
i don't know for sure like what was
originally planned what they've kind of
been
improvising because it sort of felt like
they had godzilla
and then they started creating the
monster verse with kong skull island
and changing up godzilla king of the
monsters but the fact that this is going
all the way
back to you if this is if this theory is
to stand true
going back to the original godzilla in
2014 that's pretty neat that's pretty
cool i love that concept of it well yeah
and it actually makes the idea
that much more interesting to me the
whole idea that it would be not just a
robot but a sort of
bio-engineered sort of cyborg
thing that has a brain in it that then
can go rogue on itself like that made it
actually sound interesting rather than
kind of silly because some of the
theories you know about like oh it's
just godzilla in a fake suit
you know it's just mechagodzilla that is
one of the theories maybe i'll hear it
explained in this video even in a way
that makes me very convinced of it but
that one seems a bit sillier to me than
something like this because i feel like
it was just a robot then why isn't this
just pacific rim
before we get to another very popular
mechagodzilla theory involving a fake
godzilla
let's talk about the battle axe origin
probably the most
money shot of the trailer was kong with
his battle axe
using it as a way to deter godzilla's
atomic breath
and use it at his advantage the fans are
really starting to theorize to where
this axe is actually coming from and
even i had my own theory that i'm not
not believing anymore where i thought
the humans have built this axe monarch
went ahead and supplied it to kong after
[ __ ] houses
like instead the axe is gonna be a
hand-me-down
from king kong's ancestors now watching
back the trailer
oh everything possible so that he stands
a chance when fighting godzilla we are
greeted to an area that seems like skull
island where
king kong places his hand and most
likely
opens a door to a new world that we will
touch upon in a sec
leading him to find a battle axe that
was crafted by his ancestors
even in previous monster verse movies
they have already given us hints that
godzilla
and king kong have fought before at
least
[Music]
this is not something new they just
can't seem to get along
and more than not kong's ancestors were
most likely having the most difficult
time
fighting a godzilla with that atomic
breath dude
that makes so much more sense the real
mystery will be how monarch discovers
this place because from the shots of the
trailer it looks like they're the ones
leading kong to
the area you can see the floating ships
in the background
that looks like they might be in
reference to another kaiju gamera that
is also a very popular
thanks to some copyright issues it
doesn't seem like he'll be making
appearances
in this movie still worth pointing out
that little camera of monarch
discovering this land and taking kong to
it will really be a sight to behold but
speaking of this area we have to get to
the next theory and
okay i've been talking about the acts
the most popular theory that
was circulating before even the official
trailer came out with a tv spot was
released they would get in the fight on
the naval battle spot kong might lose
that fight of
that first one but in the middle of that
he would grab one of the spinal plates
and then craft to make the axe
essentially is that was like one of the
main theories and then when the trailer
came out
you do see that it looks like he's using
it on skull island
this image you pulled up here of kong
and godzilla fighting with each other
maybe it was originally kong and
godzilla maybe it was their ancestors or
something like that
this concept sounds like it's probably
going to be the case
that it's in the acts as imbued within
the lore and the history
of the battles they've had it before
that they're passed down that they're
fighting isn't like kind of a
traditional battle of sorts you know
yeah
yeah those things that just always
happened and will always continue to
happen yeah and then
to have the axe imbued in the history of
it sounds
actually more cooler and way cooler and
makes more sense to have it be included
in the movie
i like the idea of like grabbing the
spinal plate and then
iron manning assembly swelling yeah
whatever the hell kong would do
the origin of his tool-making ability i
think that's cool there's a part that's
cool but
and doing it in the dna of the
characters actually just makes it that
much more neat when you look back on the
teases that they've done leading up to
this movie
yeah absolutely i mean yeah i love the
idea of that and it's funny because
like all these at least up till this
point all these theories are making this
sound even better than i could
i'm like please let these things be true
because yeah then it makes it like an
actual even though it might not be
a big focal point like a character thing
yes for a column
i love that undoubtedly godzilla vs kong
will finally
be confirming and introducing the hollow
earth theory now the hollow earth theory
was something that was actually
introduced in kong skull island it's
mentioned by john goodman's character
bill
randa who explains the theory as
underneath earth's crust
there are pocket spaces where complete
ecosystems are inhabited
by a bunch of kaiju that have yet to
step foot on earth and this is also
where we get a bunch of these titans
coming
out of nowhere in all these monster
verse movies
if we look at shots of the godzilla
trailer is definitely stepping
into some really out of world locations
one place in particular
where he's fighting you can even see it
looks like there are some
upside down mountains above oh yeah
essentially this being right here a part
of hollow earth
where kong goes into in order to find
his battle axe that his ancestors have
left behind two's i think
actually
and how they'll choose to expand the
monster universe
if given more sequels i also want to go
ahead and point out because i see a lot
of people saying that this is kong
on top of godzilla and as much as i want
to see that
because i'm team harry cheeks this is
kong on top
of a godzilla painting that is glowing
blue
not actually godzilla himself before
getting to the theory of how the hollow
earth sets up the ending
for godzilla vs kong and the future of
the monster verse we have to talk about
one of the number one theories everyone
is going around mentioning and that's
that king
kong is not fighting godzilla here we go
fans are really starting to heavily
theorize now that the godzilla that
appears
in the trailer is in fact not godzilla
at all instead
is an imposter and is also mecca
godzilla
i wanna curious a lot of details point
to this being the case
convince me chris this is something that
they've already done
in the previous godzilla movies one of
the very first movies that had
mecha godzilla versus godzilla it was
where mechagodzilla was wearing this
sort of godzilla skin suit before he
finally went ahead
fleshed it off and then fought godzilla
in his full
robo prime it seems that they could be
taking inspiration for that and bringing
it over to godzilla vs kong
and giving us a good reason for why king
kong and godzilla or at least a version
of them
would fight we all knew something was
awful in the trailer when they were
trying to ping godzilla to be a villain
when in the previous movies he's done
nothing but save humanity
yeah fight for them try to protect as
many people as he could
that this sudden changing character just
did not make a whole bunch of sense
the biggest debate with this though is
this fake godzilla wearing a skin suit
terminator style where
as the battle continues kong is fighting
this fake godzilla
will he slowly be tearing away to actual
fake skin
revealing i mean that's where that would
look
awesome about that king kong is gonna
take that ax to his face
once that blow is done if godzilla
stands up and
then looking at a half godzilla half
robot face
oh this movie can have all my money in
the world if not that they could go with
the more advanced
way of doing things that could make
sense with godzilla being basically all
made out of chrome
and that is that he projects a sort of
hologram around him that makes him look
like godzilla even in some of the shots
of the trailer where we first see what
we think is fake godzilla going up to
fight king kong
there is some orange liquid coming out
of his mouth and his hands slamming onto
this naval base
it turns a little blue and electric
which would be a weird effect for when
godzilla is smashing some
ships they would blow up not really turn
blue and have this electricity effect
that could be the hologram acting up
even the shot of the tail in use
underwater that does not really seem
like a godzilla tail
and looks a lot more mechanical this
would be really awesome
but at the same time it would kind of be
a cop out because for the majority of
them that's my word we're not really
getting
godzilla versus cars we're getting mecha
godzilla
kong some fans are even worried that
godzilla might not even
be in the movie at all and he might be
some sort of luke skywalker
where is he i heavily believe that's
wrong and that godzilla would most
likely show up
towards the end of the battle either
when kong is at his wits end
about to lose unless this movie is
really going to pull off the
misunderstanding that whenever kong
looks at real godzilla he thinks it's
the evil godzilla and fights him there
and
misunderstanding but without the ability
to speak
it's perfect that does lead me to how
godzilla vs kong will most likely
end in it okay before we get to that
buddy there are some sound theories here
he's wearing the skin suit okay like the
electricity moments the thing with the
tail
sure but the thing though that is making
this popping into my mind
is the shot that they have when mecha
godzilla is going
going into the city now i believe
mechagodzilla is
in this movie undoubtedly but in that
shot with the city you do
see that it's it's mecha godzilla
it's not wearing a skin suit so i feel
like
the audience would know like i love the
idea
of having this battle between kong and
godzilla
and then the skin starts coming off and
you start seeing the mechanical
underneath it like that sounds really
cool visually that sounds awesome makes
you think of yeah terminator or i kind
of think of like in rebels when ahsoka
and vader fought each other
[ __ ] like that but that shot with the
crowd does put kind of a dent
in it because he's not wearing the skin
suit now is that shot supposed to be
like later on
at post fights it was like a naval
battle fight this nighttime fight
that goes all the way into the day you
know
i mean it could be it's just gonna be a
one super long ass battle so i'm not
opposed to mechagodzilla being
in here and maybe the misunderstanding
thing will work better because i don't
like the part that feels like a cop-out
to me
we want to see real godzilla versing
real king kong
absolutely i don't want to have it be
like it's really
mecha godzilla i feel like that one
actually just a risk version
i feel like it would undermine it i
don't mind like they eventually work
together to fight mecca godzilla or they
think that godzilla's really doing stuff
and he has a skin suit but
there has to be a real fight between
them it can't just be mecha godzilla
versus kong
yeah i'm with you i feel like it would
be really fun to see
although i feel like there's something
that's just like
a crossover into cheese for me about
that if you've got like ah the skin's
ripping off like i feel like it would be
cool
but i feel like it would be another
level of cheese for this universe but
then again
i thought cheese works for you it does
you know it
all depends on it it's a giant loser
versus a giant ape
well yeah but you know the way they
totally sell these movies is like oh
it's gonna be like the most
intense thing ever though so uh yeah i
mean but i do i do side there as well as
like
okay if we're gonna have an impostor
godzilla then it better lead to some
kind of misunderstanding conflict
between real godzilla and real cons
that we can at least yeah get the actual
build
fight and not just you know uh quick
team up but if there's something imbued
in their history between kong and
godzilla like uh they have like a
vendetta towards each other or something
like that i don't know i don't think you
need the mislead or the misunderstanding
element for them to fight
we'll see i just want to see them fight
the rio it's not going to really fight
yes that's all that's all we want but
that does leave me to how godzilla vs
kong will most likely end and it will be
the cop-out that
everyone is thinking the whole one will
fall tagline that they're promising us
that one of these kaijus
will fall to the ground and be done with
then that is mechagodzilla the fake
godzilla will be the one to fall
but that still leaves us with king kong
and godzilla
out there and their ancestors are
enemies so much so that kong literally
has an
axe meant to fight people of his kind
this is where the hollow earth theory
comes back
in and will give us the explanations for
how these kaijus will live
in peace on one world and that's where
kong will retreat back
to hollow earth that'll be his new skull
island where he'll rule amongst those
animals
heck would not even be surprised if this
is the ending shot
of king kong just ruling that territory
and making his place known
while godzilla will remain above the
earth protecting the citizens and the
cities and if there's ever an avengers
level threat out there where an even
kaiju like a mecca ghidorah then that is
where the two
and fight again for the earth but those
are just some theories that fans are
theorizing and going on about with this
godzilla vs kong trailer in the end i am
just super excited for this film
i just want to see these titans collash
i'm hoping that i can get a chance
when it comes out i want to hear from
you guys which theories do you believe
in which do you think are complete
anything and everything or if you have
your own theories you want to add on be
sure to leave that down below as well
don't forget to hit that like button
purchase the shirt in the description if
you want to support the channel
and subscribe and help me hit 250.
thanks so much for watching guys but as
always my name's chris
take care congratulations on your
success buddy
chris killing the game i mean that
sounds like a really
sound theory for how it would end
absolutely those the parts of where they
would separate
separate and go i mean i i don't think
either one of them are going to die
i mean i think one will fall literally
false that one the other one's gonna
feel really bad about it and help him up
and be like you know what we shouldn't
be doing this i mean they're promising
that one will lose so
i mean it could refer to mechagodzilla
not so sure about
like the tagline's attack line all right
that's not really the plot the theory of
where they'll go their separate ways for
the holo theory
and where godzilla goes actually that
sounds really cool leaves the door open
for them to
team to have a team-up movie a godzilla
and kong versus someone you know
yeah yeah well it's actually funny
enough getting me excited
for like the lower potential of these
movies which this franchise hasn't
actually done as much as i have enjoyed
certain aspects of it like the monster
fights are always amazing but these
theories actually have me excited about
you know
that side of the development and yeah i
love that idea that you know kong might
go back to the hollow earth and rule
there
either that or maybe that shot is like
some kind of earlier prologue showing
his ancestors in his prime or something
like that but either way i love that
whole aspect of this yeah man
i think these are all pretty awesome i
can't wait for this movie
you should be writing for hollywood this
sounds so cool
sounds so cool all right guys well
subscribe to 3c films you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification
bell hit that like button we'll catch
you guys soon